we start tonight with a massive stunning
development that should have Hillary
Clinton very worried tonight The Daily
Beast reporting the Department of
Justice has in fact reopened the
investigation into Clinton's server
scandal now according to that report
investigators are now gathering
information about how Clinton and her
top aides handled classified information
including questions about how much
classified information passed through
her unsecured server who put the
information onto the server which
investigators knew about all this and
when did they know about this also
breaking tonight John Solomon who will
join us from the hill reporting that the
FBI has also opened a brand-new
investigation as it relates to the
Clinton Foundation and they are trying
to determine whether or not any
pay-for-play occurred while Hillary
Clinton was serving as Secretary of
State we have been saying and I've been
saying on this program 2018 will be the
year that all of these scandals
boomerang back on the left the media the
Democratic Party and tonight it's all
beginning to unfold now for example take
tonight's new information about the
Clinton's server scandal and couple that
with the DOJ now looking into the
Iranian one scandal and we're also
learning that the DOJ will give house
investigators access to all of the
documents and all of the witnesses in
the Russia investigation and the dossier
investigation now all this means all
this information about the Clinton
bought and paid for Russian propaganda
that fake news salacious dossier the
Russian dossier will finally now see the
light of day
you got to buckle up it's going to get
very interesting now also tonight we'll
get back to that in a minute look if you
don't work or live inside the mainstream
media and their giant well incestuous
almost like bubble well then you might
have seen that the economy under
President Trump is on an absolute tear
this is good news for forgotten men and
women in this country take a look at
these numbers Dow Jones now soared today
to over 25,000 its highest number ever
the job market continues to boom ADP
reporting today 250,000 new jobs created
in December alone which is the most in
nine months for that survey and take a
look at this headline job cut
announcements in 2017
see the lowest level since 1990
challenger report says and here's
another headline manufacturing in the US
just accelerated to its best year since
2004 and earlier today the president is
moving to now open up offshore drilling
that's right off the coast both coasts
and in the Gulf which is vital to
America becoming energy independent the
lifeblood of our economy and that's just
only some of the good news from this
week alone unemployment a 17-year low
four point one percent under President
Trump before the 250,000 jobs 1.7
million jobs were created that's now 2
million jobs african-american
unemployment in America is now at a
17-year low food stamp uses at a
seven-year low two million fewer people
using food stamps now under President
Trump in one year home prices are up 6
percent the Trump administration has now
taken a chainsaw to burdensome
regulation from our government and for
every new one they created in terms of
regulation 16 have been slashed and cut
away there's GDP so far we have seen two
quarters of over three percent growth
and remember Barack Obama the only
president in the history of this country
to never reach three percent GDP growth
for an entire year now here's what the
media will never tell you well there's a
night and day difference between the
economy just a year ago and now under
Donald Trump for one year and under
Obama's economy I'll remind you it was
god-awful
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s 95 million Americans out of the
labor force the worst economic recovery
since the 40s the lowest homeownership
rate in 51 years 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
in poverty 43 million total living in
poverty under Obama in just one year the
economy is now turning around and that's
before the 1.5 trillion dollar historic
tax cut even had a chance to take effect
all good news for us
and liberals the media they said all the
tax cuts are going to be terrible for
the economy it's only going to benefit
corporations by the way corporations
don't pay taxes turns out to be a big
fat lie
pass the cost on to US companies like
look Bank of America Wells Fargo US Bank
Southwest Airlines and others American
Airlines Fifth Third Bank even comcast
the parent company of conspiracy TV
MSNBC Wow because of the tax cut that
given their employees $1,000 bonuses and
pay raises other companies have said
they will invest now billions back into
the US economy build factories and
manufacturing centers and hire new
employees not to mention you the
American people will soon start to see
money in your paychecks where it belongs
it's all because of what this tax bill
that the media said was god-awful it
just shows you how clueless and how the
media lies to you daily and frankly how
much they hate President Trump they have
this Trump hating obsession which I told
you about last night which means that
they will do and say anything to try and
hurt him on a daily basis let me tell
you how it works
because I told you all about CNN he
actually called him a demented liar and
then conspiracy TV NBC has to say no
that's not enough he's really he's not
only demented he's deranged and a
pathological liar and they talk to each
other what we have now is a media so
corrupt they're all a bunch of sheep
they're brain-dead they're hypnotized
and it's like watching a horror movie
unfold before our eyes
remember only days ago the media wanted
you to believe we were on the verge of
nuclear war with North Korea well why is
that because unlike his predecessors
President Trump refused to be an
appeaser and capitulate to the threats
of Kim jong-un in North Korea watch the
media's hysterical coverage as they lied
to you president essentially daring the
leader of nuclear-armed North Korea
tonight to prove that his button works
this is our world now 16 tweets today to
start the new year some of them deeply
disturbed but these are the messages
from a person who is not well from a
leader who is not fit for office Trump
needs to be medicated in hospitalized
or he is going to just kill all of us
his recent tweet about North Korea and
the nuclear button the size of the
nuclear button button that has raised
alarm bells not just for from Democrats
but from Republicans as well now that
frenzy display was two days ago from the
media White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders slapped down the press for
attacking the president good for her
let's watch this should Americans be
concerned about the president's mental
fitness that he appears to be speaking
so lightly about threats regarding a
nuclear plant I think the president and
the people of this country should be
concerned about the mental fitness of
the leader of North Korea he's made
repeated threats he's tested missiles
time and time again for years and this
is a president who's not gonna cower
down and he's not gonna be weak and it's
gonna make sure that he does what he's
promised to do and that's stand up and
protect the American people understand
48 hours ago your media was losing their
minds and predicting all potential
nuclear fallout
well that was of course until Steve
bannon's comments about the president
surfaced then the narrative magically
shifts away and changes and the world is
going to end at any minute and then they
find a new best friend that's right oh
let's see a guy they've hated forever
they have uncontrollable glee that Steve
Bannon a guy that they hate said
something about the president it just
shows you how pathetic all of these
people are now look at how breathlessly
they are covering the bannon's story did
they ever tell you a single thing about
the economy that's good anything that
Trump's done good if the dog bites the
beast things if you're feeling sad in
the media's world it's all Donald
Trump's fault what's this new
revelations from a soon-to-be published
book are rocking the Trump
administration tonight portraying
President Donald Trump as a volatile and
uncontrollable force within the White
House President Trump issued a statement
like no presidential statement ever
before in American history lambasting
his former campaign and White House
senior strategist Steve Bannon in no
uncertain terms now it seems Bannon his
turned on his old boss Bannon on the
record saying things implicating him in
the Russia probe and that suggests
Trump's oldest son and son-in-law
committed treason
you now have Steve ban and the guy that
they all would have had their arms
around and had their thumbs up taking
pictures two days ago now Steve Bannon
is talking about treason and that
bombshell book rocking the White House
Michael Wolf's fire and fury inside the
Trump White House it features blistering
attacks on the president and his family
from Steve Bannon the strategies by
trumps side during the campaign and the
early days in the White House it has
drawn a furious response from President
Trump this is how bad it is look at the
graphic from CNN fake news Jake Tapper
and the one he used earlier today to
talk about the new Michael Wolf book
mental fitness really now in a way I
feel sorry for a fake news Jake he has
to take his marching orders from his
Trump hating soon-to-be scandal-plagued
boss Jeff Zucker who's best friends with
Matt Lauer the media could barely
control themselves over the banning
story and you can bet they will drag
this out as long as possible until the
next crisis they create comes along and
if it's nuclear war coming
two days later they'll forget about it
here's the thing when it comes to the
media in this country they're biased
abusive attacks against this president
president are unprecedented but you know
what in a way they've always shown their
liberal bias the media has been an
extension of the Democratic Party for
decades here's the proof they have a
long history of breathless hysterical
reporting but only when conservatives or
Republicans are occupying the White
House the media's also bent over
backwards to praise the presidents they
so love adore and worship like Bill
Clinton and Barack Obama people that
appease murdering dictators and despots
now let's start with President Ronald
Reagan this is where our history lesson
begins tonight back in 1984 you might
remember it was a microphone check he
was doing a weekly radio address that oh
he's going to destroy Russia with nukes
he was joking keep in mind this was
never in the actual real speech listen
to this
my fellow Americans I'm pleased to tell
you today that I've signed legislation
that will outlaw Russia forever in five
minutes okay
of course the audio was released
immediate ride to make it into a huge
massive international crisis even though
it was a joke take a look back then how
NBC News reacted it was the joke heard
around the world the one by President
Reagan about bombing the Soviet Union
and it resulted in a Soviet red alert
and it became a campaign issue in this
country by August 14th the story became
world news a major item on Moscow
television where the joke was not
treated as a laughing matter and look at
this headline from The New York Times
Reagan's gaffe and it only gets worse
from there the media couldn't stand the
fact Ronald Reagan ended up by being
strong defeating the Soviet Union and he
didn't fire a single shot and that
started when Ronald Reagan called the
communist regime what it really was an
evil empire
take a look they preached the supremacy
of the state declare its omnipotence
over individual man and predict its
eventual domination of all peoples on
the earth they are the focus of evil in
the modern world
so in your discussions of the nuclear
freeze proposals I urge you to beware
the temptation of pride the temptation
of blithely declaring yourselves above
it all and label both sides equally at
fault to ignore the facts of history and
the aggressive impulses of an evil
empire to simply call the arms race a
giant misunderstanding and thereby
remove yourself from the struggle
between right and wrong and good and
evil well he didn't give them billions
of dollars Reagan President Reagan was
confronting evil in his time but then it
was way too much for the media the
liberal media to handle since they
prefer the Apollo policies of let's see
bowing and kissing rings and appeasement
here's a quote from the New York Times
describing Reagan's speech quote in the
long run however the greater danger lies
in mr. Reagan's vision of the superpower
relationship as good versus evil and is
near proclamation of holy war against an
evil empire well it turns out the
so-called paper a record just like the
rest of the
Media was completely wrong if Reagan
followed the media's advice the Soviet
Union who knows might still be standing
next remember george w bush he labeled
rightly so Iran Iraq and North Korea the
axis of evil you may remember this North
Korea is a regime arming with missiles
and weapons of mass destruction while
starving his citizens Iran aggressively
pursues these weapons and exports terror
while an unelected few repressed the
Iranian people's hope for freedom Iraq
continues to flaunt its hostility toward
America and to support terror the Iraqi
regime has plotted to develop anthrax
and nerve gas and nuclear weapons for
over a decade states like these and
their terrorist allies constitute an
axis of evil arming to threaten the
Peace of the world how do you describe
in the last century alone let's see over
a hundred million human souls destroyed
is that not evil here are some of the
headlines after george w bush's speech
immediately thereafter response to
terror has Bush overstated North Korean
threat question mark allies here sour
note an axis of evil chorus and even
years later the media is still attacking
Bush's speech take a look at these
examples from the media Research Center
up until that moment Iran was
cooperating with the United States on
the border of Afghanistan it was post
9/11 Iran was more or less an American
ally by being included in the axis of
evil it turned the Iranian government in
a completely different direction it was
a turning point in American politics and
in foreign policy when Kim's father Kim
il-sung feared the US would use nuclear
weapons against his country that
historic fear was reinforced 50 years
later when the u.s. labeled North Korea
part of an axis of evil with Iran
Arak Kim jong-il feared he would always
be next after Iraq the media eviscerated
President Bush but he was right now just
take a look at Iran in North Korea today
Bush was able to see back then that they
needed to be confronted head-on and as
for the media well they can't stand the
kind of tough and direct acknowledgment
that America does have enemies that
there is evil in our time and apparently
they would rather their presidents
bending down and kissing the rings and
bowing and kissing the feet of murdering
dictators let's go back to the early
1990s Bill Clinton sucked up groveling
to Kim Jong Un's father Kim jong-il and
giving North Korea billions in energy
subsidies allowing North Korea to keep
their nuclear fuel rods and then goes on
TV and tells you there's a great deal
for the American people what a lie that
was take a look this is a good deal for
the United States North Korea will
freeze and then dismantle its nuclear
program South Korea and our other allies
will be better protected the entire
world will be safer as we slow the
spread of nuclear weapons South Korea
with support from Japan and other
nations will bear most of the cost of
providing North Korea with fuel to make
up for the nuclear energy it is losing
and they will pay for an alternative
power system for North Korea that will
allow them to produce electricity while
making it much harder for them to
produce nuclear weapons the United
States and international inspectors will
carefully monitor North Korea to make
sure it keeps its commitments only as it
does so well North Korea fully join the
community of nations today we know his
bribery or attempted bribery of
dictatorship failed now despite the
obvious flaws backed them with the deal
with North Korea the media praised Bill
Clinton's efforts they loved him what's
this deal that could end the
long-running crisis with North Korea
over nuclear weapons it could also ease
tensions on the Korean Peninsula and
open the way for normal relations
between the US and one of the world's
last old line
communist states beyond the details
North Korea seems to have made a
fundamental decision that the Cold War
is really open crucial inspections are
being delayed five years while the rest
of the deal is implemented American
officials say the delay is a small price
to pay for getting North Korea to shut
down its entire nuclear program you know
you would think that media would learn
from history learn the lessons of
history but they didn't because they're
all a bunch of brain-dead sheep with an
agenda back in 2015 just like President
Clinton we had President Obama proudly
announcing a nuclear deal a hundred and
fifty billion dollars to the mullahs of
Iran threatening to blow us and wipe us
off the face of the earth along with
Israel watch this today after two years
of negotiations the United States
together our international partners has
achieved something that decades of
animosity has not a comprehensive
long-term deal with Iran that will
prevent it from obtaining a nuclear
weapon
this deal demonstrates that American
diplomacy can bring about real and
meaningful change change that makes our
country and the world safer and more
secure this deal is also in line with a
tradition of American leadership total
BS total susan stupidity and what obama
forgot to mention oh he gave the radical
mullahs that are saying enchanting death
to America and Iran he gave them a
hundred and fifty billion of your
dollars plane loads of cash and other
currencies and Tehran they're still
allowed to keep and spin their
centrifuges which puts them on the path
towards building a nuclear weapon once
the deal runs out just like North Korea
the media they didn't care about then
any of this they were quick to he preys
on Obama the Peace Prize winner the US
and world powers reaching a major
agreement with Iran blocking one of our
biggest rivals from developing a nuclear
weapon the president is about to deliver
a statement on this historic nuclear
deal reached with Iran overnight this
agreement it's supposed to freeze that
country's pursuit of a nuclear weapon
has the US and its allies successfully
blocked Iran from making a nuclear bomb
at least for now but tonight the United
States could be entering a new era in
its relationship with Iran I think it
begins to change the dynamics of a tense
relationship of 36 years between
Washington and Tehran I think the deal
provides more than the United States
anticipated and I think it could help
prevent an arms race in the region that
would be detrimental to not just the
Middle East but to the whole world
that's the night Hannity history lesson
it personifies your media in this
country for who they are they are afraid
of strong leaders that dare to confront
evil in our time they are people that
love capitulation and appeasement even
though it fails every single time if you
really want to know how the media wants
a president to behave on the world stage
then take a look at this picture take a
look right there oh yeah so what is our
history lesson prove the media has been
and will continue to be mindless liberal
left-wing radical ideologues that no
longer report the truth they might only
like president Trump if he sucked up to
what radical mullahs in Iran and kissed
Kim Jong Un's ring is that what they
give them billions guess what that's not
something this president will do